I never expected having a child to
change my identity in so many different
ways
see I love working I really like working
and I love being a developer I love
being an engineering manager I love
solving hard problems every day and I've
always worn a lot of hats I work at
github as the engineering manager for
Adam as well as for another team that's
working on a secret product reimagining
fun and collaboration in code I'm also a
Mozilla tech speaker on the board of
Ruby together and I run a podcast called
parent driven development about being a
parent in tech I have stickers for all
of these things so if you want to chat
about any of them please come find me
I've also been a community organizer a
mentor a developer and entrepreneur a
CEO oh and then all of a sudden I was a
mom so this is Devin he was born in
April 2015 this talk is going to have a
lot of pictures of him as well as his
sister so Devin's a full-blown toddler
now and joined by his sister Leila who's
just over a year so today I want to talk
about the challenges people who are
parents and developers face as well as
what some solutions are and how these
solutions can help a company and an
entire team so when Devin was about five
months old I felt like I was losing my
mind
I've been back at work full-time for a
while if you want to hear a separate
rant come and talk to me about maternity
leave in the States and after a
particularly bad week of very little
sleep at night and having a really
challenging work week I just I really
wasn't sure if I could do it how was I
going to keep learning all the things
that I need to be learning while being a
great mom a great employee and
an adequate partner how did others do it
was I being unrealistic was I being lazy
could I even be a good mom and a good
developer or was this industry just
truly not for me
and if I'm being really honest there
have been many times in the past four
years where even though I love tech and
I love code I've thought about how nice
it would be to just go and do a job that
I could do on autopilot I seriously
thought about leaving the industry you
see these cute pictures of parents or
kids on Facebook or Instagram but it's
not always like that and for me in the
early days it definitely usually wasn't
like that it was hard it was tiring it
was frustrating it was also amazing and
all-encompassing it was really really
lonely based on what I was experiencing
I created a survey to ask parents a few
questions about this issue and when I
found out from reading hundreds of
surveys if there is that there are some
real trends and common issues in an
industry that values open source
contributions github as your resume and
keeping up to date with the most recent
programming developments parents are
struggling so let me take a second to
describe a typical day from a few months
ago so Devin wakes up around 7:00 Leyla
around 7:30 which is already pretty
amazing a lot of parents day is start
closer to 5:30 or 6:00
I would nurse Leila while Devin has sort
of a glass of milk and then by 8:00 8:15
we like really need to get moving
get everyone dressed brush teeth make
car breakfasts you can feel free to
judge but I am NOT a morning person my
son is not a morning person car
breakfast is what works very well for us
and at 8:45 our nanny comes which is
already a huge privilege by 9:00 I
dropped Devin off at preschool by 9:25 I
was home pumping breast milk usually
while making coffee eating breakfast and
starting to check some emails then I
would jump into the workday do that
punctuated by a few more breast milk
pumping breaks until about 5:15 at 5:15
I raced out the door I grabbed Leila put
her in the car we go pick up Devon from
preschool we try to get home by 6:15 and
then from 615 to 7:15 and my husband and
I drew dinner for the kids sometimes try
to cook our dinner
cleanup dinner in Toya's bath time
bedtime etc from 7:45 until around 9:00
we finished cooking we dinner we clean
up we prep food and bottles for the next
day jot down any childcare notes talk
about any person it happenin toweled
stuff that we need to we usually relax
for like 30 minutes and then we head to
bed and we have it pretty good
even with two now fortunately this was a
day from a couple of months ago I got a
lot more time back in my day as I weaned
my daughter and didn't need to pump
breast milk dropping the number of times
that I had to pump in a day felt amazing
I had more time to concentrate and
didn't have to go through this huge
context which every two hours and I
mentioned this tangent because pumping
breast milk was mentioned in over half
of surveys for mothers and their answers
about company provisions or issues they
faced now the only time in that whole
day that I would have to do any code for
myself would be those last 30 minutes
that I have to relax and even if I gave
up that little bit of self-care time my
brain is so tired by then I wouldn't get
anywhere fast and if you think about
this in terms of code challenges that
often need to be completed outside of
your workday for new jobs parents may
have to spend the whole weekend just
working on a couple of code challenges
which also means depending on a partner
or spouse to do the child's care and not
seeing your kids this might not seem
like a big deal
but when you're already working full
time it really is and this of course is
even more challenging if you're a single
parent if you're a single parent and
you're likely pay
for weekend childcare to get these code
challenges done another issue you
mentioned was being able to stay sharp
so developers live on coffee and solve
really hard problems if you are a
nursing mom you're probably getting
significantly less sleep and you can't
rely on all of those cups of coffee to
keep you going
a recent study from outlet baby care
found that over 40% of parents with
babies ages 0 to 6 months only get one
two three uninterrupted hours of sleep
per night parents lose a total of 44
days of sleep in their child's first
year and a newer study found that
parents are sleep deprived for six years
after they have a kid and I'm like
really selling this parenting thing
right now it's hard to keep a clear mind
and solve hard problems when you're not
getting uninterrupted sleep and you
don't get the weekend to catch up or
recharge a parent wrote sometimes the
last thing I want to do or even have
time to do when I get home is code or
learn new code gone are the days of no
responsibility and doing whatever I like
when I get home finding a couple of
hours to work on a personal project or
pick up something new is hard especially
when trying to help out my other half
who's also tired when I asked if having
children helped or hurt their career
only a small portion of fathers said it
hurt their career they felt it either
helped or had a neutral impact about 60%
of women said that having children hurt
their career but even more than that
said it didn't hurt their career but it
changed it many women said it slowed
their career affecting the overall
trajectory and growth potential now I
don't know about you but that
description certainly sounds like
hurting mother's careers to me so here's
the total breakdown of parents based on
if they felt that having a child helped
hurt had no impact or both helped and
hurt their career and here are those
same traces
based on mom answers and dad answers so
as you can see when everyone's together
the portions are pretty equal but as you
break it down it tells a much different
story and this data is backed up by
additional research this 2018 study on
children and gender inequality in
Denmark shows these results based on
gender and earnings in Denmark which I
know at least for most Americans
consider much closer to the gold
standard in terms of supporting parents
so while there are lots of challenges
that parents face there are also lots of
solutions looking at these surveys there
are identifiable solutions that
companies can put in place solutions
that colleagues with or without children
can employ and things that parents out
there can also work on these solutions
can actually benefit an entire team so
we're gonna start with the company based
ones first allowing work from home
remote or unconventional working options
even once a parent is ready to come back
to work offering different working
options can make a huge difference in
their happiness level for women who are
pumping being able to work from home
makes an enormous difference for me when
I worked from home I could pump in 22
minutes because I had everything set up
and ready to go but anytime that I went
into an office
it took me 32 to 34 minutes each time
cuz I had to set up cleanup and the
travel time just to get to the room hope
that nobody's in the room etc hopefully
this isn't as much of an issue in Europe
or outside of the states but I wanted to
mention it again because over half of
surveys from women suggested issues or
difficulties around pumping if you have
women at your company that are pumping
in the bathroom your company needs to
seriously consider how they prioritize
mothers in the work force allowing
working from home takes the stress of a
commute out of the equation and allows
parents a little more flexibility and
time in their day another option is to
offer a part-time transition back to
work so surveys showed that people took
this in different ways some working less
hours some working less days but a
gradual transition back to work for
pretty much as long as a company can
allow it makes an enormous difference in
a parent's lifestyle
second companies can take a much more
proactive role in creating support
systems so a really simple example of
this might be a parenting slack channel
where parents can share experiences
issues and pictures of their kids a more
involved option might be to connect
parents returning to work with those who
have taken parental leave in the past
and allow for it to be a safe space for
both parties to discuss successes issues
and challenges
finally train managers on what to expect
when someone who has been on parental
leave comes back to work this is
important for moms and dads but for moms
in particular oftentimes managers in
tech may have never had a mother go on
maternity leave on their team they have
no idea what challenges that woman is
facing what questions might help or hurt
her return to work transition and how to
best support her as both an employee and
a colleague over and over again I saw
quotes like my boss was a big part of my
success when I was a new parent third
create realistic expectations for
parents returning to work if your
company operates off of KPIs or
goal-setting recognize that these goals
should be revisited when parents come
back to work and set new goals these
goals will likely not be as ambitious as
they've been in the past if you're a
manager encourage realistic goal setting
and if you're an employee recognize that
your whole life has changed
give yourself at least a quarter or two
to adjust to the new normal as your
children get older you'll become more
aware of what effective goal setting and
realistic expectations looks like for
you fourth if you have children or if
you don't have children or for majority
of your team is childless
don't make parents stuff weird right
talk about nursing or pumping or kid
things in whatever way feels comfortable
so one of the things that I did when I
was back in the office after my first
was create an emoji for when I was away
from my computer pumping this helped me
feel open and honest about what was
going on and it did so in a way that
didn't make my team feel awkward or
weird about it after my second I just
stuck my pumping times right on my
calendar so folks didn't schedule
over them my previous company I did a
lightning talk for the engineering team
I did too while I was pregnant about
what that was like and I did one
afterwards about the science of breast
milk and pumping my team has some really
interesting questions and they had much
more empathy and understanding for me
afterwards and my hope is that by
exposing them to some of the terminology
and experiences there'll be more
understanding and empathetic to any
women or parents they might work with in
the future but this should not be
incumbent on the pregnant individual to
do so managers should have an
understanding of these facts and also be
willing to be the one that helps their
team understand these considerations so
again those are creative working options
support systems realistic expectations
and normalizing it when things like
creative working options support systems
realistic expectations a normalization
of someone's life choices are
incorporated into a team or company's
culture and has positive benefits for
the entire company the open acceptance
of diversity and intentional support
around the uniqueness of a teammates
life creates that kind of atmosphere on
a team as managers and company employees
are trained to establish and seek out
things like support systems or create
realistic expectations anyone going
through any sort of hardship or life
adjustment will feel supported once
you've created these systems and
benefits it's easier to see how similar
accommodations for others enable teams
to thrive support systems could help
folks from burning out and normalize it
being open about struggles and successes
makes it more likely that someone who is
burning out will speak up earlier
realistic expectations encourage teams
to craft better guidelines around work
and promotions which often help
underrepresented minorities succeed and
creative working options help companies
attract the best talent regardless of
where they reside there are also things
that we can do as parents first
get rid of your parent guilt which is so
much easier said than done so I'm going
to tell you a story about Halloween when
my son was a baby when he's six months
old I saw two Halloween costumes for him
and there have been so many homemade
costumes since then the picture of both
my children those are the costumes that
I frantically finished sewing about
eight hours before I had to fly to
Malaysia to speak at rubyconf Malaysia
now why because for me I feel like
spending this time after the kids have
gone to bed making their costumes of
course that's the reason why my kids
feel like they're my top priority right
no that's ridiculous that's a ridiculous
statement I know it's a ridiculous
statement
it's a ridiculous statement to say but
oftentimes working parents feel this way
we feel bad and we feel like we're
ordering too much takeout or we miss a
special activity but we also need to
realize that working and doing something
that we love is just as important for us
and for our children to see a mom said I
thought I was a bad mother and a bad
developer because I didn't make
everything perfect next schedule of
self-care days so it probably took me
about a year to do this but the first
time that I just took a random day off a
day where my son was in childcare my
husband was at work and I didn't pack my
day filled with filled of ketchup work
or household chores I felt so refreshed
we don't get the weekends to recharge
and vacations are really not vacations
once you've had a child so it's
important to not put these days off and
to make sure that you're taking at least
one every couple of months just to
recharge next optimize the time that you
have available so as I mentioned before
a lot of surveys talked about being
really aware of the finite amount of
time that parents had to do work so make
sure that you're making the most of
these hours set learning goals focus and
figure out how to hack your day to
create as much time as possible to
advance whatever goals you're putting
forth for yourself
we can only make this better if we are
united so it wasn't until I truly felt
like I was caving under the stress that
I reached out to other mom developers
and it wasn't until I reached out that I
learned that lots of people felt the
same way that I did I found some
excellent communities of moms in tech
and it's made a huge difference being
able to speak with one another and share
challenges solutions and suggestions is
invaluable just like having a support
group when you have a newborn supporting
one another as parents in tech makes us
stronger and better and gives us a more
United voice next share that mental load
so I'm going to talk about moms for a
moment because mothers are
disproportionately affected by the
weight of mental load although this
happens in most partnerships in 2015 the
Pew Research Center surveyed about 1800
parents and households where they both
work they asked who does the work of
managing your children's schedules and
activities and who takes care of the
kids when they're sick Marie Kondos
recent series on Netflix was often
touted as a prime example of women being
crushed by responsibilities and to do
items I mean the number of moms who who
I talked to who told me that they sat on
the couch and cried while watching that
show because they felt the same way it
was truly incredible the New York Times
had an article in February about working
mothers in Japan and it spoke about how
working mothers often work more than 49
hours a week and typically do close to
25 hours of housework a week while their
partners do an average of less than five
so let's say you have a partner and
let's say your partner is great which
I've actually found is already a pretty
big assumption and let's say that you
feel like you've got a pretty good split
of work you share pickups and drop-offs
you share who stays at home with the
kids on days off you share cooking and
cleaning etc but what about the other
stuff so who thinks about what the kids
are going to eat for lunch
who schedules doctor's appointments who
knows what days school is gonna be
closed
who knows what child needs next
developmentally and then what's coming
after that who buys the birthday
presents for birthday parties that are
coming up who reviews homework who plans
and packs for family trips if you're
already splitting this load than I
applaud you
but for many families this is not the
case so if you're not doing it already
share that load I have a link in
resources at the end to a worksheet that
can help jumpstart this conversation one
example of what I did was put a
checklist on our door of who needs what
in order to leave the house in the
morning I did this because I realized
that I was taking on the mental burden
of having to make sure that everybody
was ready in the morning even on the
days that my husband was doing drop off
with this list we can both make sure
that everyone has everything they need
without me needing to be the one that
there is that burden finally if you need
to leave your company leave your company
ultimately if your company doesn't
understand the lifestyle of you as a
parent and doesn't allow you to be with
your children when you need to be and if
you can try to leave this advice came up
over and over again in surveys although
admittedly a lot of surveys up until
this point have been filled out by
senior level developers so I think have
a little bit more flexibility in this
area so that's disappear parent guilt
self-care days optimize your time find a
community share the mental load and
leave if you have to for your teams
remember that just existing as a parent
on your team makes your team's better
you are organized you need to set
boundaries and you must have some sort
of work-life balance being this role
model helps everyone even if they don't
know that your role modeling it a little
while ago my team had an off-site which
I brought my family to and in order for
me to be available for dinner and
bedtime each evening our day ended at
5:00 and we didn't meet up for dinner
until 7:00 or 7:30 my team actually
brought this up in our retro is one of
the things that they loved about our
off-site schedule not knowing that I had
created that break because I needed to
balance running the off-site with being
present for my family
when I told them the reason why the
break existed they saw that not only did
that benefit me and my family but it
also benefited them by giving them a
chance to recharge before evening
activities finally we're going to talk
about what colleagues can do cuz
colleagues with or without children have
lots of power to make things better for
teammates and make companies better in
general so first asked about lactation
rooms if you live in a country where
moms are still pumping when they return
to work so I was at a conference once in
America
and I needed to place the pump and I
asked the front desk person if there was
a space other than the bathroom to do so
and he said I think we have a supply
closet somewhere that you can use
fortunately there was a security guard
standing nearby who walked over and said
my wife's going through the same thing
I'm sure we can do better than a
bathroom or secure our supply closet and
let me look around for you quickly and
sure enough they found me an empty
office but mothers shouldn't be alone in
this fight if your company is moving
into a new space or spending money
building something out suggest that they
make appropriate accommodations for
mothers returning to work and if they
don't know what those are there are
plenty of women who would be happy to
talk to them about it second just be
friendly this one's really easy but when
folks are coming back ask how they're
doing coming back to work can be really
emotional and so just checking in
showing them that you care and that
they're appreciated and supported really
makes a difference third make your voice
heard someone suggests working late or
scheduled late meeting see someone
criticizing a parent for needing to take
time because their child is sick or has
a doctor's appointment parents often
feel really guilty about taking this
time or saying I have to go I have to
run to pick up my child it's helpful for
others on the team to speak up as well
and say something like I know this
meeting is running over we want to be
respectful of those with the hard stuff
or is there any chance we can schedule
this meeting a little earlier I know it
doesn't work for everyone's schedule and
finally if someone uses a word or
concept that you don't know google it
I like to think that most of us are
pretty good at Google and we all
generally like learning new things so if
you don't know what pumping is if you're
curious about childcare costs if you've
never heard of a sleep regression or
anything that a parent mentions on your
team just google it there's some great
resources out there to learn more so
that summary is lactation rooms be nice
speak up and use Google while there are
specific things that colleagues can do
to help parents these actions benefit
everyone and make teams stronger these
suggestions boil down to increasing
empathy and curiosity and an interest in
your colleagues in their lives as well
as a desire to understand one another
when these factors are incorporated into
a team's DNA it leads to stronger more
effective teams that can support and
understand one another more effectively
you may ask about lactation terms
specifically to support parents on your
team but you're also learning to
recognize different situations where
different accommodations are helpful
you're learning how to support teammates
by asking questions and figuring out how
to be a better Ally on your team and
teams that are strong in these areas
help attract and retain more diverse
talent there's some great resources out
there you can take a look at how your
company is doing or how companies that
you're looking at are doing these
include in her site fairy God buzz as
well as a link to my site with
additional resources like that mental
load worksheet the number one piece of
advice that I got on surveys was that
you'll never get this time with your
children back so value it prioritize it
and try to guard it as much as possible
there's some days that I still feel like
I'm not sure I can be a successful mom
and in tech but there are some days that
I can give a hundred percent to both
areas and others where I feel like I'm
letting either my family or my job down
oftentimes though I find myself calling
on developer or manager strategies for
effective parenting or vice-versa I
personally think this makes me a better
manager it gives me more experiences and
strategies I can call upon in a variety
of situations what I also learned
through speaking with hair
and people and the amazing parents that
that answered a few questions is that
the struggles that I face are not unique
it's important for all of us as a
community as developers as colleagues as
peers and as managers to think about
this I thought that everything that I
was feeling was just me but it's
everyone everyone has similar concerns
and how do people have the same issues
so let's think about how we can make it
better because they're solvable as peers
with or without children managers CTO as
directors of engineering we can make the
lives of parents in tech better which
will ultimately make our teams and
companies better the user says this
research is ongoing so feel free to
check out my Twitter if you want to fill
it out and parents as one person wrote
on their survey just high-fives
you're awesome be confident thank you
[Applause]
[Music]